welcome to this video against black
operator black operator
I'm the black operator in this game
actually I got the Kalashnikov here
again okay he Duke here might be three
that's not the most exciting move but I
really have no idea about it but he dyf
is good right takes night eggs should be
a really convenient for black getting in
all this him quickly
okay night before we going what should
be fun yeah well he has to he has to
play Bishop before everything else looks
really bad hmm
so then f5 for yeah let's be ambitious
here with f5 maybe it is too much but
need to have some kind of ambition
I mean he has to play he has to play
Bishop before yeah there is simply no
other move okay yeah okay you can do
that of course and give up on any kind
of hope for an advantage if you just
give up your Bishop so what is this idea
d4 alright so let's see that the ephod
is closed I mean I've got two bishops
now and the pawn on d3 as a as a target
let's cancel out of it yeah he's getting
ready to play d4
completely completely trading everything
Bishop e6 he can play maybe night to c5
or Bishop to c5
okaywell d4 it's not a threat or
anything it just traits traits the whole
board Bishop c5 is also bit bit annoying
oh okay
that is a strange move it just goes just
runs right into in 294 okay let's let's
play that it's very close to to losing
material here in some in some lines at
least Knight takes pawn takes just wins
the piece for me Bishop takes pawn takes
Knight e4 and here hmm five maybe
okay well I'm definitely alright maybe I
should have thought about it a little
bit more just in terms of timing yeah
I'll be sure before it's got Knight f6
the thing is strategically speaking this
is fantastic but the the matter is do I
get it
do I get it to work from a technical
point of view
f5 Knights it's pretty active
hmm yeah the decide didn't play well 94
looked very tempting but it wasn't the
that wasn't the best move from with some
certainty it looked very inviting of
course him to play simply because
Queenie to just steps into the e-file
but it's really not that that big of a
deal okay
Naru creator agents patent
yeah we've got two bishops against two
nights which in many cases is completely
enough to win the game because the
bishops are so much stronger but one
issue here is this is somewhat weak porn
what knocking he allows me to take yeah
I will take that I will take that okay
so their reason not to take that rope
could be one quincy - no I can't take it
okay look see one right on f5 wait wait
I can also play f5 in this position
isn't this good f5 I don't see the point
at the moment
Night Moves d2 is hanging in book c1
wasn't especially bad but at five oh
that's that's a neat reply if I take
here Queen takes
green cheeks I can take it - but that's
not sure time we're sure to win this
she takes Queen takes Queen a - it's not
okay
hmm jinx jinx I can just move the Queen
also what about the time here why did I
spend all the time on the smooth that's
very stupid
yeah even if it if I get to a position
where I'm just two peas up which might
happen could be tricky will be tricky to
win
yeah this is such a piece of position
but 30 seconds is not exactly a lot of
time
he's spending quite some time as well
which is helpful
should keep five it's coming Jack okay
now my numb up one time actually okay I
cannot take you should see to or to d3
okay come on this this pawn is doing a
home run now Jack Jack game drive yeah
what a shame what a shame not to win
this okay I had much more time here even
here two seconds more and it's a it's a
very very easy win technically okay two
weeks off no blitz and sometimes a bit
tricky let's let's have a brief look at
this yeah okay well this is a very
unambitious way to play and black here
already has some at least equalized but
he absolutely has to play Bishop before
I mean not doing this is really
conceding everything yeah I mean after
this black is just just better just two
bishops former for for nothing the
question is how to play it which is not
so easy
you have a quite a range of good
possibilities the the engineer stockfish
is suggesting f5 which I didn't think
about looks a bit loose this move but it
has an idea of your stay like pushing
all the way through yeah one point is
that this is really really bad
f5 is not bad but ok rook e8 it it is it
will always be better for for black
because of the two bishops I was
thinking it would should play this and
sort of try to try to hold this this
kind of position where I'm like
eternally better but due to the complete
symmetry it's not so easy to win
yeah and this is a weird move it just
runs right into 90 forward it wasn't
that bad I mean maybe maybe I have have
to prepare that Bishop f5 Bishop e6 or
something this is not as good as it
looks at first yeah I was thinking
initially yeah that I mean this is not
working
yeah and f5 is was the other idea but if
you look at this look at this position
I'm in a pin here and it's not so easy
to unpin I cannot even go Bishop e6 yeah
this is what I was thinking is this
maybe but the problem is that my
development is not good yeah I have two
bishops against two knights but I have
nothing out yeah and it's it's not clear
it's not really clear this is a thing
much better in comparison now he I'm
catching up in development now rooks see
one rook c8 and now he just yeah just
gives gives me this this material here
for no compensation whatsoever yeah the
question is really this is this is very
tempting this wasn't my original idea
isn't just consistent just this just
good I mean it's probably winning
exactly this kind of thing and now b5
just with very clear intentions you know
- - that's all - - during jutsu that I
didn't see route b7 of course I was
thinking I 5 wins apiece basically which
is yeah he gave me the he gave me the
piece he can do this counter checking I
have this idea I mean sorry he has nine
f1 ok what he just gave me the piece ok
yeah of course I must win the game but
the the time situation irritated
irritated me of course
yeah Bishop g2 is even more precise but
okay it's it's a matter of the matter of
playing that quickly and this is a win I
just have to have to be a be precise iam
um what is the easiest actually probably
this right blocking blocking the whole
thing yeah this is this is good yeah he
can try to advance it but I will
ultimately push him back and then I will
pick up the pawn seven I can always lose
Tempe with the bishop it's a pretty easy
win but I was a little bit too too
nervous say maybe with the time okay I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching